blanc
rouge
bull
[Musique]
j'ai dépensé beaucoup de dollars sur
l'hiver que j'ai quand même quand je
fais attention mais est quand même les
règles de base qu'on peut suivre et moi
je dis toujours on peut avec des petits
moyens très bien avoir un verre pour
tous on peut s'amuser avec des verres à
80 dollars pignol eu des choses
extraordinaires mais on l'a tous vu dans
les bars ou si tu as peut-être moins
intéressants comme expérience il ya peu
un des choix qui m'inspire un lieu qui
me rappelle beaucoup de souvenirs par
contre lesquels avaient celui là je sais
pas c'est parfois joyeux les batailles
parfois triste mais finira aimait
souvent triste pour le vin offre
concrète avec toujours plus quand je
reçois les gens la maison j'ai un type
de verre et je sors dans ce bar l'eau
tous les bulles le blanc le rouge
pourtant tous ces choix de verre nous
font tourner la tête
mais gardons sa simple voyons surtout ce
qu'il faut éviter
d'avoir un rack est clair une fois on
voit les verts roses des verts orange a
donc sans couleurs ont bu un verre
transparent on veut voir la couleur du
vin c'est vraiment partie du plaisir de
la découverte la robe la couleur en
vouloir un pied je sais que maintenant
nous beaucoup de verre 100 pieds ça
c'est parfait pour le camping lorsqu'on
s'en voit aussi elle parle technique au
parc mais c'est sûr que lorsqu'on
obtient le vert par le val le ballon on
vous réchauffer l'hiver on veut pas
réchauffer le vin donc on va vouloir un
verre un pied et tenir le vert par le
pied du vert prend garde tous les jours
on veut s'assurer d'abord invoqué
peut-être légèrement plus épais les plus
résistants
donc par choix manque de places ou plus
petit budget pas de souci le vert idéal
est là pour nous servir à tous les jours
à la maison levac j'utilise blanc rouge
bull c'est l'arrivée l'ouverture pour
moi sans aucun doute si mince ces
résistants il ya un pied c'est élégant
donc j'ai toutes les grandes lignes ont
fait de ce que je cherche dans un verre
sont les entretiens très bien et qu'on y
fait attention mais ce vers l'eau
envisagée puis ils vont mesurer un très
très longtemps notre vie vient tout à
coup de se simplifier
champagne
je ne déteste les flûtes à champagne
l'ouverture d'une flûte à champagne
c'est très étroit alors si j'ai une
grande bouteille de champagne par
exemple et que je veut maximiser
justement les arômes j'ai besoin que le
vin soit en contact avec l'oxygène dont
une ouverture plus grande si vous
regardez ici dans l'afflux on comprend
pourquoi on veut servir les bulles pour
le niveau esthétique un visuel on voit
que lille bull c'est un mouvement
continu ont pu les observer c'est grand
c'est beau je vais ressentir les trois
verts juste qu'il a rompu nous dire si
vous voyez une différence au niveau
d'expression du vin by bull
champ beaucoup plus dans celui là oui
c'est beaucoup plus directement
exactement c'est vraiment marqué vos
messages
mais si on à l'espace et le goût de
s'adapter davantage on pourrait en
choisir un pour le blanc et un pour le
rouge je prendrai la forme pour le blanc
on appelle ça la forme du risque
lorsqu'on va détails on peut demander le
blanc riesling ou sauvignon blanc puis
le rouge bordeaux donc là on voit dans
quelque chose en occuper au gain que le
ribay l'ouverture ici on désire vivre
l'expérience gustative total avec un bon
vin il y en a pour tous les goûts et
surtout à tous les prix
sans nenê moyens comme aller chez grin
côtoyer un mois c'est les altos je peux
plus me séparer de ses vers l'un d'eux
puis j'ai découvert c'est vers là
c'est une compagnie autrichienne c'est
soufflé à la bouche c'est l'hiver qui
sont très dispendieux je crois que le
moins cher des altos est autour de 80
dollars le vert et ça monte mais vous
dites cadeau si l'on se demande quoi de
mieux ou aux amoureux du vin vraiment
que c'est le plus beau cadeau vous
pouvez faire parce que ça va durer déjà
dans la manipulation j'ai l'impression
d'avoir
un bijou c'est tellement france est
tellement mince
sur la table un vin blanc de bourgogne
trois types de verres et de grande
différence
c'est parce que j'ai j'ai l'impression
que c'est pas le serment de même 20 je
vous laisse et déguster vous allez voir
aussi que le v ne touche pas la même
partout dans la bouche dans les trois
verts
jerry shen à cet exercice ne m'était
jamais arrêté à ça c'est vraiment
étonnant de voir comment le liquide se
dirige tout est vraiment dans la bouche
et avant de l'avoir en bouche j'ai hulot
darquy tard elle est beaucoup plus
intensément moins qu'en prenant ces deux
verres
pour l'entretien de tout mon verre il
faut les laver à l'eau très chaude et
éviter le savon qui pourrait laisser une
odeur désagréable dans les coupes on
peut mettre un petit mélange d'héroïne
bilingue dans l'eau pour dégraisser vert
si vous voulez prendre un savon premier
un savon vraiment neutre pour les suit
on veut tenir le var par le bol il ya eu
vraiment doucement jamais tenir le vert
par le pied est tournée parce que là on
va devenir vraiment brisé le pis les
grands verre soufflé à la bouche vous
avez aucune chance ils vont vous car ses
dents limées et après yeux des lieux des
linges donc derigent microfibre qui vont
vraiment polir votre var parfaitement
plusieurs endroits propose ce format de
coop ridel vin rouge sous différents
noms et les prix varient de 12 à 18
dollars en magasins spécialisés
est-ce que les ridelles qu'on peut
retrouver parfois arabe et dans des
grandes surfaces est ce que c'est la
même qualité c'est souvent un verre
inférieur aux qualités on va miser plus
sur le cosmétique que sur la qualité du
verre donc ça ressemble mais c'est pas
exactement la même chose et la qualité
du var est pas exactement la rue
[Musique]
alors vaut mieux ne pas lésiner et
rechercher le riz dès l'ouverture vin
rouge
on est dans le plaisir donc pourquoi pas
justement pays un ou deux dollars de
plus des fois la différence est très
petit pour avoir
ce plaisir
[Musique]